bon je vais vous parler de votre pouvoir
d'achat
ou plus exactement de la baisse de votre
pouvoir d'achat
c'est à peu près ce qui vous attend
alors on est donc reparti vous savez si
vous mettez boutabout ce que je vous ai
raconté la dernière fois c'est à dire
que l'énergie gouvernent le monde est ce
que je vais vous raconter aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que la production va
baisser
bah y'a pas besoin d'être grand clerc
pour arriver à la conclusion que il va
se passer des choses curieuses sur le
système de prix on parlait tout à
l'heure à la cafétéria des vocations des
élèves à la sortie de l'école là à les
faire de la finance quand le monde réel
va connaître des turbulences qui l'a
jamais connu jusqu'à maintenant vous
risquez d'avoir quelques surprises
j'en reviens donc à ce que je disais
tout à l'heure la production théâtrale
si j'ai un conseil à vous donner allez
allez voir le monde réel avant d'aller
voir le monde financier vraiment de
surprise la production et les couverts
vous ai dit tout à l'heure on
généralement des profils qui se
ressemble à peu près et je vais
compléter vous voyez ici ce que je vous
ai raconté là tout à l'heure il ya deux
pays qui ont déjà passé leur pic de
production dans les courbes que je vous
montre les etats-unis la france
en voici quelques autres là vous avez
par exemple l'indonésie qui produit à
peu près 1,5 million de barils par jour
dans les années 90 un moment où la
production globale de pétrole est à peu
près de 80 eh bien vous voyez que
l'indonésie a passé son pic en fait elle
a passé son plateau et ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on va retrouver en ce qui
concerne la production de pétrole
mondial ça n'a pas été un pic francs net
clair et précis qui s'est passé une
année donnée un jour donné et un mois
donné c'est quelque chose qui a oscillé
autour d'un niveau d' équilibre pendant
dix ou quinze ans avant de commencé à
décliner de manière franche et vous
voyez que quand vous êtes cette année-là
en indonésie bah vous savez pas encore
si vous avez déjà passé le pic ou si
vous êtes en train de skier sur le
plateau ou si vous avez un petit
accident passager avant que ça ne
remonte vers le pic qui sera pour plus
tard
ce que je suis déjà en train de vous
dire sur cette courbe sait que le pic
est quelque chose qu'on
vérifiera de manière certaine que ex
post on sera absolument certain quand il
sera derrière nous on sera pas
absolument certain quand ils vont nous
dire je dois faire une précision
importante à la suite d'une remarque qui
m'a été fait là pendant la pause je vous
disais que les réserves ultimes c'est
quelque chose qui par définition est
intemporel les réserves ultimes louis
l'appréciation qu'on en a non alors ça
peut vous paraître de la sodomie
diptères mais il faut bien voir qu'il ya
eu différence absolument fondamentale
entre les deux
l'intégrale de moins l'infini à +
l'infini tant vous n'êtes pas plus
l'infini vous savez pas ce que ça vaut
donc vous avez une appréciation qui est
nécessairement subjective sur la partie
futur qui va contribuer aux réserves
ultimes donc les réserves ultimes la
définition est intemporel l'appréciation
qu'on en a varié au cours du temps donc
ce que je vous ai donné tout à l'heure
quand je vous disais les géologues ça
fait à peu près 35 ans qui donne un
ordre de grandeur qui restent à peu près
le même sur les réserves ultimes
il faut donc comprendre ça comme sur
cette notion qui en elle-même est
intemporel l'appréciation temporel elle
est à peu près constante depuis 30 ou 35
ans encore une fois la définition est
intemporel l'appréciation allaient
nécessairement bad et j'en reviens à ce
que je disais c'est une incidence les
gens en vie à ce que disait donc voilà
un pays qui a passé son pic
l'indonésie depuis quelques années voilà
un autre exemple de pays producteurs qui
a passé son pick and roll a depuis
beaucoup plus récemment que les années
90 depuis 2000 qui est la grande
bretagne laventure pétrolière dans la
mer du nord a commencé dans les années
70 donc c'est quelque chose qui est très
récent la grande bretagne est devenu un
producteur de pétrole après le premier
choc pétrolier c'est monté très vite ça
s'est stabilisé d'une certaine manière
avec des oscillations autour d'un niveau
d'équilibré et là c'est en train de
redescendre tout aussi dit prenez
l'autre grand producteur de la mer du
nord qui est la norvège est bien la
norvège c'est pareil elle a passé son
pic de production alors lui a été
franchie d'une manière plus nette
mais encore une fois je vous répète ce
que je vous
tout à l'heure tant que vous n'êtes pas
cinq ou dix ans derrière vous ne savez
pas si vraiment le pic a été passé ou
pas alors maintenant on va prendre un
pays qui est plus rigolo qui est le
venezuela
le venezuela a passé son pic de
production vous étiez pas encore né le
venezuela a passé récemment un pic
secondaire parce que le venezuela à une
courbe de découverte ce qui est une
courbe dromadaires et non pas une courbe
de chameau donc il ya eu deux cycles
dans les découvertes au venezuela
et donc il ya eu deux bosses mais c'est
clairement la première bosse qui a été
la plus haute
pas beaucoup mais elle a été un peu plus
haute donc le vrai pic du venezuela a
été passé dans les années 70 le pic
secondaire a été passé lui par contre
beaucoup plus récemment et la production
de pétrole vénézuélienne est
actuellement en train de décliner
alors y'a un p'tit vélo venezuela c'est
qu'il ya des gisements de pétrole qui
s'appelle dé pétrole extra-lourd donc
non conventionnelles donc ça c'est pas
la totalité de la production pétrolière
pour le coton conventionnel
on a passé le pic encore un pays pour
lequel le pic a été vraisemblablement
passé et là je dis vraisemblablement
parce que vous voyez que la partie
secondaire là c'est quoi encore en train
de redescendre c'est la russie aux dires
des géologues pétroliers
la production de pétrole russe qui a été
jusqu'à 12 millions de barils jour dans
un monde qui à l'époque en produisait 60
ou 70 donc c'était vraiment un
producteur un key player un producteur
absolument majeur la production de
pétrole russe est descendu elle est en
train de remonter à à peu près 10
millions de barils jour mais les
géologues pétroliers à qui je parle
pense que ça montera pas beaucoup au
dessus de 100 donc le pic principal de
production du pétrole russe est
probablement quelque chose qui s'est
déjà produit là aussi vous étiez pas
très vieux parce que ça fait à peu près
une vingtaine d'années donc là vous
voyez un certain nombre de pays pour
lesquels soyez clair qu'ils ont passé
leur pic soit il est vraisemblable
qu'ils ont passé leur pic et alors dans
les vrais semblables en voici d'autres
voici par exemple mexique il est
vraisemblable que le mexique a passé son
pic de production parce que là c'est des
damnés qui vont jusqu'en 2006
données 2007 montre un déclin très nette
est en fait il semblerait que ce soit
caractéristiques des champs offshore ou
en général la montée en puissance et le
déclin vont plutôt plus vite que dans
les champs terrestre donc là vous avez
encore une fois l'exemple du mexique
on peut se poser la question mais le
plus vraisemblable c'est que ils
viennent de passer leur pic ou pas loin
donc à vous voyez un pays dont elle a
aujourd'hui la production mondiale de
pétrole est à 87 millions de barils jour
je vous ai dit les anglo saxons avaient
des unités exotiques donc tout à l'heure
on a eu dans des barils maintenant on
est à des millions de barils jour c'est
ça l'unité de production du pétrole
eh bien regardez le mexique qui vient de
passer son pic est à peu près à 3500 la
russie qui est vraisemblablement en
train de passer son pic et à 10000 prat
10 millions par dont le venezuela qui
vient aussi de passer son pic a priori
secondaire était aux alentours de 3,5
millions de barils par jour ça c'est des
milliers en fait donc vous avez un
certain nombre de pays qui sont pas des
petits acteurs sur la scène de la
production mondiale qui ont déjà passé
ou sont en train de passer leur pic de
production
alors maintenant on va aller au monde
dans son ensemble et la question c'est
bien évidemment qu'est ce qui se passe
pour le monde dans son ensemble alors
une première chose qu'on peut dire pour
le monde dans son ensemble s'est pas à
quand le pic sait déjà combien on a
sorti de pétrole de terre voilà ça c'est
un premier truc qu'on apprécie de
manière à peu près raisonnable et jeudi
de manière à peu près raisonnable parce
que je vous ai dit la dernière fois que
en ce qui concerne l énergie qui faisait
l'objet de transactions commerciales
c'est là qu'on avait les statistiques et
plus fiables il n'empêche que vous avez
quand même une part d'erreur même là
dessus et vous avez de la contrebande et
vous avez des gens qui payent pas les
impôts et vous avez d'agde
l'autoconsommation sur place et vous
avez ceux ci et vous avez cela ce qui
fait que même là dessus vous avez selon
les banques de données des chiffres qui
peuvent varier de quelques pourcents ben
là dessus donc ce qui s'est passé c'est
que la production de pétrole
elle était à peu près de 10 millions de
barils par jour il ya 58 ans elle est
montée progressivement jusqu'à plus de
80 millions de barils par jour
actuellement donc elle a été multipliée
par un facteur 8 par un facteur 8
depuis la date de naissance de vos
parents ou à peu près qui n'est pas
petit et on avait fait sortir de terre à
la fin 2005 à peu près un milliard de
barils de pétrole
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que la
quantité totale de pétrole extractible
sur terre était évaluée entre 2 et 3000
milliards de barils donc on a deux à
trois mille milliards de barils de
pétrole extractible aura déjà fait
sortir mille donc même si vous êtes très
fatigué vous devriez arriver à faire
deux à trois mille - lille ça veut dire
qu'il reste 1000 à 2000 jusque là je
pense qu'on est à peu près d'accord
admettons que là on est dans le côté
très conservateur de la sphère le
pétrole qui reste sous terre soit
intégralement contenues dans les
réserves prouvées corps on a aujourd'hui
à peu près 1000 milliards de barils de
réserves prouvées en fait 1200 donc
imaginons que tout le pétrole est
contenu dedans alors à ce moment le pic
il est maintenant l'année prochaine dans
deux ans la semaine dernière le 1er
janvier 2005 à 18h15 comme dit jérôme
bonaldi enfin bref on y est en gros on
est dans le sillage on que je vous ai
montré à l'échelle d'un pays tout à
l'heure et c'est le cas à l'échelle du
monde on est déjà rentré dedans
le scénario le plus probable se cale sur
l'estimation la plus probable des
réserves ultimes restantes c'est à dire
1500 milliards de barils si on à 1500
milliards de barils de pétrole
extractible restant alors le plateau
parce que ça va vraisemblablement être
un plateau de production à échelle
mondiale comme pour un certain nombre de
pays que vous avez vu est en vue encore
une fois est-ce qu on y est ce que ça va
être 2012 2 etc
enfin bon c'est pourtant pas très
longtemps
en tout cas et vous allez avoir une
production qui va rester constante ou
quasi constant pendant n'importe quoi
entre 5 et 15 ans et ensuite il va y
avoir un déclin il va y avoir un déclin
quoi que ce soit
l'automobiliste français le conducteur
chinois et la personne possédant une
chaudière au fuel ya un journaliste de
capital à qui j'ai fait la remarque
l'autre jour qui est que dans un monde
dans lequel la production pétrolière
déclinons pouvait pas avoir de
consommation croissante
il m'a dit ah c'est vrai je vous signale
que les élus ne s'informe
essentiellement qu'en lisant la presse
donc vous n'aurez pas quels que soient
les bobbies n'est ce plan présenté
aujourd'hui aux banquiers de monde dans
lequel la production fait ça là
consommation fait ça selon là n'existe
pas on va dire mais vous rigolez mais
aujourd'hui 99 99% des banquiers n'ont
pas compris et 99 avec 99% des élus
l'ont pas compris non plus et 99 avec
99% des aménageurs publics n'ont pas
compris non plus tout le monde pense que
le monde va continuer comme il a
toujours continué jusqu'à maintenant et
que jusqu'à que vous ayez mon âge ça va
continuer comme ce qu'on a toujours
connu
non c'est probablement pas ça qui va se
passer on peut être oui oui
alors vous n'avez pas écouté tout à
l'heure vous les réserves ultimes
c'est une évaluation de la totalité du
pétrole extractible disponibles sur
terre ça incorpore donc comme je
l'expliquais tout à l'heure le restant à
réévaluer restant à découvrir restants
et c'est donc ce n'est pas basée sur les
taux d'extraction aujourd'hui ça
incorpore l'anticipation que vous pouvez
faire de l'amélioration des taux
d'extraction future salle incorporent
déjà alors vous avez une limite physique
importante en ce qui concerne les
hydrocarbures sa part quand je n'ai pas
dit tout à l'heure qui est que vous êtes
nécessairement dans un contexte dans
lequel quand vous avez besoin d'investir
plus de 20 kilowatts heure pour faire
sortir un kilowattheure vous avez plus
une réserve donc quand le taux
d'extraction
quand je te dire la capillarité la
porosité l'huile résiduelles et ces
fonds que vous avez besoin de mettre
plus d'un kilowattheure dans le pompage
que le kilowattheure qui va être
contenue dans l'huile qui va sortir
souvent du reste à ce stade mélangé à de
l'eau on injecte de l'eau dans le
réservoir pour le laver entre guillemets
on ressort un mélange
il faut aujourd'hui vous avez des
gisements en arabie saoudite où ce qui
ressort de manière brute du réservoir
ses 84 au sein de flottes donc vous
injecter de la flotte pour sortait la
flotte qui a lavé le réservoir avec 5 %
d'hydrocarbures vous séparer les deux et
vous récupérez les hydrocarbures ou et
enfin tant que c'est énergétiquement
rentable on peut le monter et puis quand
c'est plus énergétiquement rentable on
s'arrête mais encore une fois là où on
va s'arrêter
c'est parce que énergétiquement il ya
une barrière à la on va s'arrêter
il ya une barrière franche n'est pas
nécessairement qu'on n'a pas
nécessairement touché aujourd'hui mais
il ya une barrière tranchant tout état
de cause qui est que physiquement si
vous investissez plus un kilowattheure
pour faire sortir un kilowattheure quel
que soit le prix de la ressource
vous n'avez plus accès à ses plus de
réserve encore quel que soit le prix du
pétrole c'est plus une réserve
et personne n'en sait rien c'est ce que
je vous ai expliqué tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui les réserves ultimes sont
évalués nécessairement avec une
appréciation subjective du taux
d'extraction au dessus duquel il n'est
pas possible de monter du volume de
réserves de pétrole en place kylie a au
total sur la planète donc tout ça est
bourré de bach d'erreurs et
d'incertitude et chacun fait sa propre
évaluation
ce qui est important c'est de savoir ce
que pensent les gens qui travaillent
dans le secteur et de voir s'ils ont un
avis convergent à partir du moment où
les gens qui travaillent dans le secteur
qui sont ceux qui sont plus près des
informations primaire ou un avis
convergent
mon conseil c'est que de faire le pari
inverse de tous ces gens là est un truc
extrêmement casse gueule donc en
d'autres termes quand les professionnels
du secteur commencent à converger sur un
ordre de grandeur qui est à peu près
constant le pari qui consiste à dire moi
qui j'avais foutu menée sous terre je
sais bien que je préfère éviter mais
c'est simplement
encore une fois c'est un exercice dans
lequel vous avez une bonne partie des
données qui ne seront connues avec
certitude qu'une fois la partie terminée
et vous pouvez pas faire autrement
mais par ailleurs il faut quand même
savoir que vous avez un siècle de
géologie pétrolière français 1859
normalement mais je veux dire avec des
moyens modernes
vous avez entre un demi siècle et un
siècle avec des dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui sont passées là dedans
donc on ne sort pas de rien on va jouer
dira le taux d'extraction c'est pas un
truc qu'on découvre quand on discute
dans un bistrot je veux dire c'est ce
qui préoccupe tous les ingénieurs de
toutes les compagnies pétrolières dès
lors qu'ils travaillent dans
l'exploration-production ils pensent
qu'à ça donc vous permettez cette
expression donc donc c'est encore une
fois un débat technique qui est nourrie
nourris et le nourrit et re re nourrit
de manière extrêmement importante les
mêmes questions
alors le pétrole réutilisés pour
extraire et en quantité extrêmement
minime parce qu'en fait pour extraire du
pétrole vous avez besoin de pompe de
mort en gros vous avez besoin de moteurs
de machines tournantes
donc vous allez avoir besoin d'un peu
d'énergie mécanique c'est pas quelque
chose qui est en règle générale
monstrueux donc dans la majorité ça je
vous montrerai après c'est indirectement
contenu la question vous poser dans le
coût d'extraction du pétrole actuel et
vous verrez comment ça serait parti mais
en gros aujourd'hui il faut retenir
l'idée que la quantité d'énergie
dépensée dans l'amont de la chaîne
pétrolière donc pour que vous ayez un
kilowatt heure dans le réservoir de
votre voiture
il faut que la chaîne pétrolière qui va
de l'extraction jusqu'au raffinage et à
la distribution est consommé à peu près
0,15 kilowattheure corps donc c'est une
énergie soit dit en passant qui a un
excellent rendement d'extraction de
raffinage et de distribution absolument
excellent vous devez dépenser à peu près
10 à 15 % de ce que vous extrayez pour
assurer la totalité de la chaîne depuis
le réservoir rochus jusqu'au réservoir
bien qu'ils se ressemblent pas de la
voiture donc j'en reviens à ce que je
disais la version la plus pessimiste
entre guillemets c'est il nous reste
plus qu'un milliard de barils
donc c'est demain matin on y est là où
pic il nous en reste encore 1500 c'est
le début d'un plateau dans pas longtemps
et soit dit en passant le début d'un
plateau c'est le début du découplage
entre la croissance démographique des
consommateurs et l'approvisionnement
donc c'est le début des tensions
économiques 1 on n'y a pas besoin
d'attendre le déclin et enfin on peut
commencer à rentrer dans la zone où
comme je reprends l'expression je disais
tout à l'heure on gagne au loto lundi
mardi et mercredi
donc on se retrouve dans la frange haute
on est plutôt du côté des 31 de ce qui
reste est à ce moment bas le pit idées
pour 2020 2030 2035
aujourd'hui du côté des producteurs je
parle pas du côté des consommateurs mais
du côté des producteurs
vous n'avez quasiment plus une personne
qui croient que le pic il attendra 2030
2035 et que la production pourra
dépasser les 100 millions de barils jour
le patron de total a récemment et quand
tout à l'heure de la question j'aurais
dû rebondir là dessus quand on me dit
est ce que dans votre graphique c'est
par mon graphe
ça c'est le graphique deal mathieu qui
est patron de l'évaluation des réserves
pétrolières mondiales à l'institut
français du pétrole
c'est pas mon graphique moi je suis fort
mesure de faire un graphique par contre
cet homme là dans ce métier voilà ce que
raconte monsieur de margerie dont c'est
le métier d'aller chercher de fait le
pétrole sous terre vous dit je ne crois
pas qu'on dépassera 95 voilà il ya un an
il disait je crois pas qu'on dépassera
90 et je vais vous montrer d'autres
d'autres graphique pour encore une fois
vous donner les bornes de ceux de ce
débat je vous parlais tout pouvoir
d'achat voici votre pouvoir d'achat
la question est bien évidemment de
savoir ce que va devenir le prix de
l'énergie au moment où on va passer ce
pic
je vous ai dit la dernière fois quelque
chose qui est absolument comme
fondamental et puisqu'il paraît ici la
finance est une grande tentation tous
les mécanismes économiques
je le répète et j'insiste qui ont été
acquis depuis deux siècles ont été
acquis dans un contexte de prix de
l'énergie des croissants tous ils sont
donc à peu de choses près tous inopérant
dans tout les épaules les machins les
couloirs aussi et c'est là que je vois
tout ça ça vaudra pas un clou dans un
contexte de monde dans lequel le prix de
l'énergie est structurellement croissant
savoure avant un coup là c'est peut-être
le début de ce monde là c'est peut-être
le début de ce monde là j'en sais rien
en tout cas je pense que la question se
pose et se poser ce genre de question
c'est déjà le début de mon aventure
parce que encore une fois aujourd'hui à
peu près personne ne se la pose alors
quand même quelques petits trucs qu'il
faut rappeler pour que vous ayez un prix
de marché pour vous ayez un marché ça
peut vous paraître stupide comme
remarque
mais en attendant aujourd'hui à peu près
les deux tiers du pétrole produits
passent les frontières
le pétrole est une grande baignoire
mondial on a coutume de dire c'est à
dire un endroit où producteurs et
consommateurs peuvent tous puiser dans
une même événement ou verser dans une
même marmite est puisée dans une même
marmite
vous avez des prix qui sont relativement
homogènes en ce qui concerne le pétrole
accessible d'un bout à l'autre de la
planète et vous êtes donc dans un
contexte de marché parfaitement fluide
parfaitement homogène ou à peu près dans
ce genre de contexte
il ya une première question qu'on doit
se poser c'est est-ce qu'il va y avoir
un marché où est-ce qu'il va y avoir 25
marché parce qu il est bien évident jeu
un exemple monsieur bush a envoyé ses
troupes en irak arrive le pic de
production mondiale du pétrole
monsieur bush dit moi j'ai besoin de
pétrole vous les français aussi les moi
j'y suis j'y reste donc je vais prendre
une partie du pétrole qui est nécessaire
pour alimenter mon arrivée c'est la jda
prélève 20 dollars le baril
et puis ce qui reste je le mets sur le
marché et à ce moment je le mets sur le
marché à 150 dollars le baril exactement
je laisse l'irak m le solde sur le
marché à 150 ou 180 dollars le baril
voilà typiquement un exemple dans lequel
vous aviez un marché nous en avait 2
avec deux prix de marché qui sont
complètement différents après vous
pouvez avoir dans un certain nombre de
pays consommateurs des gens qui refusent
ce qui s'est passé et ce qui finira par
arriver
ce qui s'est passé en france au moment
des chocs pétroliers c'est à dire qu'un
certain nombre d' usage deviennent
réglementé ou interdit baas il est
interdit de construire un logement avec
une chaudière au fioul
le prix du fioul pour les logements
neufs est un truc qui n'existe plus il
n'y a plus de marché donc je je encore
une fois le prix de marché et quelque
chose qui n'existe qu'une fois que vous
avez défini le marché dans ce genre
d'évolution
je parierais beaucoup de choses sauf une
qui est qu'on va garder un marché
mondial homogène non fragmenté avec un
prix qui reste le même partout et pour
tout le monde ça m'étonnerait énormément
que ça soit le cas ce sera peut-être le
câble sat est un vrai la deuxième chose
dont je suis absolument sûr c'est que la
prolongation tendancielle n'arrivera pas
or la prolongation tendancielle c'est
celle sur laquelle sont bâtis
aujourd'hui absolument toutes les
politiques publiques des états
consommateurs donc vous prenez tout ce
qu'on a coutume d'appeler les pays
riches où les pays industrialisés eux
ils ont ils font des exercices qui sont
pour lequel n'a pas besoin d'entrer à
l'école nationale supérieure des mines
de paris s'il vous plaît ils disent
à partir du moment où la consommation
passée a été comme ça une règle et ma
consommation future
elle sera comme ça alors ça ça marche
très bien quand on a des envies dans mon
physique c'est parfois un peu différent
quand on mesure la taille de 0 à 15 ans
si on fait ce genre d'exercice on
découvre qu à 40 ans je le crois mais de
et comme vous pouvez le constater c'est
pas exactement le cas donc dans le monde
physique les processus qui sont
perpétuellement linéaires sont pas assez
rare ils sont assez rares
la majeure partie des processus suivre
des règles qui sont
r vous savez très bien donc ça va être
exactement pareil en ce qui concerne le
pétrole
la seule question quand je vous disais
tout à l'heure c'est la question de la
date je préfère faire confiance
personnellement aux gens qu'ils
produisent que aux gens qu'ils
consomment
de même que si je veux savoir comment
fonctionne une voiture je préfère faire
confiance à ceux qui les produisent et à
ce qu'ils les réparent plutôt qu'à ceux
qui les conduisent mal à c'est
exactement pareil je préfère faire
confiance
tu vas faire d'eux qu'ils ont fait je
préfère faire confiance aux gens qui le
produisent donc les gens qui produisent
me dise la courbe pointillés n'arrivera
pas elle n'arrivera pas donc je suis
banquier je vois arriver un jeune
entrepreneur de l'école des mines ou
d'ailleurs qui me dit moi j'ai un
business plan absolument génial
formidable croissance de 10% et c est
juste un problème il est basé sur cette
courbe verte et rouge là bas je peux
vous dire que je le fous à la poubelle
et joue au restaurant j'aurai beaucoup
plus agréablement passer mon temps et je
n'aurais pas rendu un mauvais service à
la banque parce que à l'évidence cet
homme là est en train de cette femme ait
à rendre la vie en couleur c'est pas ça
qui va y arriver
alors est-ce que ce début le début de
cette évolution des couples et par
rapport à la prolongation tendancielle
elle est maintenant et dans 5 ans elle
est dans dix ans peu importe si vous
vous intéressez aux investissements
structurels qu'il faut faire les
infrastructures qui gouvernent notre
consommation d'énergie ont toutes des
durées de vie qui s'échelonnent entre 50
et 100 ans
que ce soit pour maintenant où pendant
dix ans ça ne change absolument pas les
décisions de politiques publiques à
prendre
voilà donc quelque chose qui est très
important c'est que dans de votre vivant
et même du bien on va voir arriver
quelque chose sur la production du
pétrole qui est l'énergie rennes par
excellence et dont le prix gouverne le
prix de toutes les autres énergies
quelque chose qui n'est pas arrivée
jusqu'à maintenant
alors ça c'est l'idf paix maintenant je
vais vous montrer total total en 2004
alors totale a été pendant quelques
années un champion de jésuitisme parce
que ils disent ils projetaient de
transparent mais c'est bien ça les a
fait sortir du bois
ce transparent était utilisé par mon ami
pierre rené bossis qui était à l'époque
conseiller de monsieur desmarest qui
était le président de total est en gros
ils disaient nous on n'a pas d'avis sur
le pic
mais je vais vous raconter ce que disent
les copains alors totalisé la production
de pétrole c'est exactement ce que je
voulais monter son graphique de lier
fait voilà ce qu'elle est devenue
et puis après si on interroge l'avenir
les gens qui sont les plus pessimistes
et qui voit le pic arriver le plus tôt
bah ils le voient arriver au niveau
auquel on est actuellement vous voyez à
peu près 80 un peu moins de 90 millions
de barils par jour aux alentours de 2010
et puis c'est les gens donnent une
association qui s'appelle association
for the study of peak om as pont et puis
les gens qui sont les plus optimistes
qui vois plutôt ça en 2025 2030 à des
niveaux qui atteignent ou qui dépasse
les 100 millions de barils par jour dès
cette époque
dès cette époque total disait les
prévisions de prolongation tendancielle
de l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
suppose l'existence d'un pétrole dont
moi opérateurs je ne sais pas où il est
donc peut-être que ces gens là qui
consomment ils ont une idée de l'endroit
où ils se trouvent mais moi qui suis
chargé de faire sortir du sol je sais
pas où il est plus intéressant alors
depuis total c'est bien avoir un avis
alors le premier avis ils l'ont eu a à
peu près 100 millions de barils par jour
à peu près en 2020 c'était monsieur
desmarest
ingénieur des mines donc personne
respectable qui a eu cet avis et puis
depuis il a été remplacé par monsieur de
margerie qui lui dit je pense que ça
remontera pas au dessus de 95 donc il
est plus bas et je pense que c'est pour
2015 dans tous les cas de figure j'en
reviens à ma règle d'airain qui est que
en aucun cas la production cumulée ne
pourra dépasser les réserves ultimes en
aucun cas
donc vous avez une contrainte sur la
production et on est dans un monde qu'il
faut optimiser dans ce contexte là on
parlait tout à l'heure d'un débat
sémantique il y en a un qu'il est
indispensable d'avoir dans ce contexte
c'est vous prenez générations futures
moubarek futur et vous remplacez par
actuelle il ne s'agit pas d'un problème
pour les générations futures
il s'agit d'un prêt pour vous moi ne
s'agit absolument pas d'un problème pour
les générations futures
absolument pas
à chaque fois qu'on parle de problème
pour les générations futures en ce qui
concerne l'approvisionnement énergétique
mondial
on se fourrent le doigt dans l'oeil
jusqu'à l'omoplate il s'agit d'un
problème encore une fois ici et
maintenant ici et maintenant
un autre exemple je vous ai cités tout à
l'heure ce monsieur al husseini
alors donc à lui seini sa date de son
petit nom était donc un cadre dirigeant
jusqu'à vous savez dans le domaine
pétrolier il ya une ressource rare qui
est le cadre dirigeant récemment
retraité est quelque chose sur lequel
j'attire votre attention parce qu'on
parlera aussi du nucléaire dans cette
salle c'est que vous avez une différence
majeure que vous que vous devriez tous
notés entre le pétrole et le nucléaire
c'est que le cadre pétroliers le cadre
dirigeant pétrolier à la retraite se
dépêchent de commencer à dire je vais
vous raconter maintenant exactement l
inverse de ce que je vous ai dit quand
j'étais dans mon univers professionnel
alors que le cadre du sanitaire ne fait
absolument pas ça ce qui est pour moi le
signe que dans un cas il ya probablement
des débats beaucoup plus important que
dans le deuxième je regarde ce que je
vous disais c'est intéressant d'écouter
ce que disent les jeunes retraités vous
avez ici une courbe qui vous donne la
production de pétrole par zone
géographique passé et un pronostic sur
la production future qui a donc été
faite par un des patrons qui avaient des
responsabilités techniques de très haut
niveau dans la compagnie qui détient les
plus grosses réserves pétrolières
mondiales c'est à dire ça veut dire à
cette communication a été faite vous le
voyez c'est pas du sepa de l'actualité
fracassante mais presque puisque ça date
d'il ya quelques mois et ce monsieur
disait pour le passé ce que vous savez
déjà
et il disait pour l'avenir et bien la
production mondiale de pétrole
alors en fait il faut rajouter les
condensats de gaz naturel mais
c'est une subtilité technique en gros on
n'est pas très loin du plateau le
maximum maximorum si tant est qu'on
doive en trouver un
lui il avait mis très exactement en 2013
et enfin l'euro reste tout ça ça ne
change pas grand chose qu'on soit là
dedans et puis ça va se mettre à
décliner à partir de 2020
dans ce contexte là dans ce contexte de
déclin global
on peut très bien avoir des zones qui
continuent temporairement à croître
c'est pas du tout un interdit regardez
l'afrique par exemple sa production
continue à croître
regardez l'amérique du sud sa production
continue à croître donc le pic mondial
n'est en rien antagoniste avec le fait
qu'on continue à trouver du pétrole en
afrique qu'on continue à trouver du
pétrole au brésil et que la production
continue à croître dans ces zones là il
ya normalement une erreur que vous ne
devriez pas faire à votre âge et votre
formation c'est de confondre une valeur
isoler une moyenne il est bien évident
que quand on regarde un agrégat large eh
bien ça ne dit pas que absolument tous
les sous-ensembles de cet agrégat vont
exactement dans la même direction peut y
avoir des variations interne
voilà donc cet homme-là vous dis pas en
gros on n'y a quasi et cet homme là qui
s'est probablement de quoi il parle a
dit quelque chose que je suis incapable
de vérifier que vous êtes incapable de
vérifier que à peu près n'importe qui
sur terre est incapable de vérifier
il a dit à cette même conférence que
l'arabie saoudite était aujourd'hui
physiquement incapables d'augmenter
significativement sa production
pardon n'est pas seul à dire mais aussi
mathieu size a dit la même chose donc le
mais voilà donc il a dit ça or pendant
très longtemps l'arabie saoudite au sein
de l'opep avaient des capacités de
production telle qu'elle occupait un
rôle absolument stratégique et clé qui
était celui de ce que dans le jargon
pétroliers on appelle le swing dieu
c'est à dire celui qui est capable de
faire de faire varier très rapidement sa
production pour l'adapter à la demande
mondiale et de faire en sorte que les
prix restent à peu près stables et dans
un monde dans lequel vous n'avez plus ce
robinet disponibles que vous ouvrir ou
fermer quelque chose qui va
vraisemblablement se passer c'est ce que
je faisais tout à l'heure c'est que les
prix vont devenir très volatil
donc ça va devenir de plus en plus
difficile de faire des projections
réalistes de ce que sont les prix à six
mois a donc tout à l'heure vous avez vu
que sur le prix du baril je me suis bien
gardé de vous dire
comme l'a fait monsieur artus qui a
peut-être raison que ça vaudra à 400
dollars le baril dans deux ans dans
trois ans donc je n'en ai aucune idée
parce qu'en plus comme je vous disais
tout à l'heure pour avoir une idée d'un
prix de marché il faut savoir ce que
sera le marché je n'en ai absolument
aucune idée aucune si j'avais eu l'idée
du reste je ferai pas de cours aux mines
je spécule reste le prix du pétrole et
j'attendais tranquillement chez moi car
j'en suis absolument certain des prix à
venir
très exactement ce que je ferais j'irai
faire de la voile donc je n'ai aucune
idée absolument aucune idée de ce que ça
peu devient j'ai juste une conclusion à
vous proposer
qui est que de parier sur une grande
stabilité à un niveau bas est à mon avis
parier sur l'éventualité la plus
improbable
vous apprécierez je pense à l'aune de
cette donnée là ce qu'il est pertinent
de faire ou pas avec les agriculteurs
avec les pêcheurs avec les routiers etc
dont je ne veux pas le malheur par
ailleurs donc j'en étais à mon graphique
sur la production alors maintenant j'en
reviens à on va revenir dans le monde
réel et je vais vous proposer deux ou
trois réflexions s'agit bien de
réflexion sur ce que cela peut signifier
en voici une première
vous avez ici avec un traitement
mathématique approprié simplement pour
que ça tienne à la même échelle
verticale c'est juste ça quelque chose
qui vous aura deux courbes qui vous
représentent l'une le prix du baril de
pétrole c'est la courbe bleue foncée et
l'autre le taux de chômage aux
etats-unis l'année qui suit et alors
vous constaterez que jusqu'en 1970 où
les états unis sont autosuffisant sur le
plan pétrolier vous n'avez pas de
corrélation majeure entre le prix du
baril de pétrole et le taux chômage
d'années qui suivrait le taux de chômage
y le prix du baril de pétrole a
relativement stable c'est une première
chose à noter
et la deuxième chose à noter chez vous
voyez que le taux de chômage se baladent
quand même pas mal il n'y a pas de
rapport évident entre les deux et du
moment où les états unis sont devenus
importateur de pétrole
quand ils ont passé leur pic et du reste
un certain nombre de gens pensent que le
pic de production des états unis et les
chocs pétroliers qui ont suivi trois ou
quatre ans plus tard ne sont pas des
événements qui sont décorrélés l'un de
l'autre
donc ceci explique partiellement cela un
des états unis sont dépendants de pays
étrangers
car en profiter pour leur faire un peu
la leçon donc vous avez à partir des
années 70 une corrélation
qui devient on peut pas dire évidente
mais en tout cas un sujet de discussion
après les élections ce qui veut dire que
si cette corrélation est valable alors
ce qui fait le taux de chômage aux etats
unis se décident beaucoup plus en sortie
depuis que au moment des élections
et ça ne devrait pas vous étonner si
vous vous souvenez de ce que je vous ai
raconté la dernière fois en vous disant
que l'énergie c'est est le premier
facteur de production qui comptait dans
l'économie et donc ce que décide madame
royal où monsieur sarkozy sera
probablement du restant de votre vie
parfaitement secondaire
devant ce que sera la quantité d'énergie
disponible et son prix c'est ça qui va
structurer le système socio-économique
en tendance lourde c'est ça qui va
structurer un deuxième exemple ce qui
n'est pas une bonne nouvelle ni pour
vous ni pour moi vous avez ici
la structure des recettes de l'état
français depuis 1978 suis désolé j'ai
pas pu trouver la série avant mais je
sais de quand date la courbe violette
duo là qui m'intéressent et 74 vous avez
ici donc la structure des recettes de
l'état français en l'état français il
peut gagner de l'argent en ayant ce
qu'on appelle les recettes de production
ils font des trucs
par exemple les monnaies et médailles
vous vendre une médaille comme ça c'est
pas grand chose il peut faire payer des
loyers
il peut encaisser des impôts
essentiellement comme ça qu'ils gagnent
de l'argent
il peut avoir des gens qui encaisse pour
lui et ses enfants mon bref ils
s'arrangent avec quelqu'un et puis s'il
n'a pas gagné assez d'argent pour payer
les enseignants les infirmières le et c
est bien il fait appel à la dette
en d'autres termes il emprunte de
l'argent en disant je paye tout de suite
avec l'argent que j'ai emprunté et puis
pour remboursement verrai plus tard
noter que l'appel à la dette
c'est-à-dire l'insuffisance de recettes
propres pour boucler des recettes est
quelque chose qui date en fait là dessus
vous ne voyez pas mais vous pouvez me
faire confiance du premier choc
pétrolier donc tant qu'on était dans les
trente glorieuses entre 1945 et 1974
le budget de l'état était équilibré ou
excédentaires au premier choc pétrolier
il est devenu déficitaire et ça dure
depuis il s'est passé quelque chose que
les économistes qui s'intéressent à la
question connaissent bien c'est que
l'état français avait ajusté son train
de vie sur une croissance de ses
recettes qui
de plusieurs points par an et la
structure de l'état étant beaucoup moins
réactives que la structure d'une
entreprise privée vous virer les gens
quand ça va mal
dupas qui faillirait les fonctionnaires
c'est juste un constat est bien à partir
du moment où les recettes au lieu de
faire ça se sont mises à faire ça le
train de vie et lui a continué à faire
ça et on a bouché la différence avec
l'appel à la dette et vous noterez que
cet appel à la dette connaît à chaque
fois des accès de fièvre
quand vous passez par une période de
récession économique qui peut notamment
être lié à un choc pétrolier dont vous
avez ici qu'elle 79 deuxième choc
pétrolier crack coût d'accès à la dette
récession qui a suivi la guerre en irak
crac repos d'accès à la dette etc alors
maintenant vous avez compris la suite de
l'histoire
ça veut dire que dans l'avenir qu'on
s'apprête à vivre l'une des conséquences
vraisemblable c'est que on va continuer
d'augmenter l'état parce que va y avoir
une récession et donc il va donc il faut
il faudra donc peut compter sur lui
alors qu'on aurait besoin de lui pour
faire les investissements structurants
parce qu'il aura pas de pognon
voilà donc vous êtes le monde réel et le
monde écrit le monde économique c'est le
monde réel
1 c'est ce que je suis en train
d'essayer de vous expliquer vous n'avez
pas le monde économique d'un côté qui se
joue à la page financière et la page
marché du journal et de l'autre côté le
monde réel qui lui serait complètement
déconnecté le monde économique c'est le
monde réel alors jusqu'à maintenant je
vous ai parlé uniquement du pétrole
on va élargir un peu le propos tout en
sachant que toutes les notions que j'ai
évoquées devant vous jusqu'à maintenant
les réserves ultimes
les réserves prouvées la produit et
c'est tout ça ça se calque extrêmement
bien sûr les autres ressources fossiles
que sont le gaz et le charbon
alors en fait jusqu'à une époque récente
on avait l'habitude de dissocier les
hydrocarbures en trois catégories
enfants au classement les ressources
aussi dans trois catégories les charbons
chez solide le pétrole ces liquides le
gaz
ces gaz ont en fait on voit apparaître
maintenant des trucs un peu exotique
intermédiaire des gaz très denses ou au
contraire des pétroles des trucs qui
sont interminables des sables bitumineux
ces intermédiaires entre le pétrole et
le charbon
ça s'est formé comme le pétrole mais ça
s'explique comme le charbon
donc on a on a maintenant une jonque
seringue une ligne de partage des eaux
de partager zéro carburant plutôt qui
est un peu il ya une partie de cette
segmentation qu'on peut considérer comme
étant artificiel donc vous avez ici la
représentation des inventaires mondiaux
ou des évaluations des inventaires
mondiaux pour ses diverses ressources
la première d'entre elles celle dont je
vous ai longuement parlé c'est ce qu'on
appelle le pétrole conventionnel donc
ton considère qu'il ya à peu près 350
300 milliards de tonnes de pétrole
extractible restant en ordre de grandeur
ici vous avez le pétrole non
conventionnel donc les sables bitumineux
avec une partie qui dans les arts
prouver une autre partie qui est dans
les réserves probables et possibles
d'encre au dessus vous avez le même
genre de raisonnement avec le gaz
sachant qu'en ce qui concerne le gaz il
ya une grosse différence avec le pétrole
c'est que le taux d'extraction spontanée
d'un réservoir de gaz est
considérablement plus élevé que le taux
d'extraction spontanée d'un réservoir de
pétrole
en gros quand vous plante et autres
tuyaux vous êtes à peu près assurée
d'avoir 60 à 70 % du gaz qui sort tout
seul sous l'effet de la pression
ce qui veut dire que les réévaluations
futur dans un réservoir de gaz portent
sur un enjeu qui est considérablement
plus réduit que les réévaluations futur
dans un réservoir de pétrole
et ça veut dire aussi que le déclin
quand on a passé le pic sur la
production de gaz va en général beaucoup
plus vite que le déclin sur la
production de pétrole
ces deux différences qui sont
significatives avec la production
d'hydrocarbures et vous constatez
surtout que dans cette affaire le monde
possède essentiellement du charbon avec
exactement la même différence entre
réserves prouvées et réserves ultimes
dans un cas vous êtes sur le sur ce que
vous considérez être absolument certain
en termes d'extraction et dans l'autre
c'est tout ce qui pourrait sortir de
terre au mieux vous avez aussi en ce qui
concerne le gaz et le charbon
une notion d'élasticité au prix c'est à
dire que si la ressource voit son prix
augmenter
alors il ya certains endroits où
s'étaient pas rentable de creuset où ça
le devient
j'avais exactement les mêmes notions la
dernière chose qu'il est important de
garder présent à l'esprit c'est que tous
ces hydrocarbures sont techniquement
interchangeables en d'autres termes on
sait depuis les années 20 faire des
hydrocarbures liquides avec du gaz ou du
charbon
grâce à deux ingénieurs allemands qui
s'appelle fisher et roig et ya au moins
une arme et dans le monde qui en a très
fortement bénéficié puis comme vous le
savez et l'allemagne n'a pas de pétrole
n'a pas d'hydrocarbures liquides ça n'a
pas empêché alors qu'elle n'avait que du
charbon de faire avancer ses chars et
ses avions et l'histoire a montré que ça
avait assez bien marché pendant un
certain temps et du reste il n'est pas
complètement exclu que cette chose qui
paraît surprenante quand on connaît
l'histoire militaire de la russie qui
est l'invasion de la russie par hitler
qu'on peut quand même se demander ce
qu'il était riche là bas alors que tous
les gens qui étaient allés avant lui
s'étaient cassé des dents on peut se
demander si en fait sans arrière pensée
n'était pas d'accéder aux gisements de
pétrole de la caspienne
parce que ils s'en sortaient plus avec
le charbon qu'il avait chez lui pour
alimenter sa machine de guerre voilà
c'est une hypothèse
moi j'ai jamais été fouillé les archives
militaires mais il ya un certain nombre
de gens qui se demandent si t'as pas
pesé si ça n'a pas pesé dans la décision
mais toujours est il part que par contre
un truc qui est absolument certain c'est
qu'il a fait avancer ses chars et ses
avions avec et que les sud africains
s'ils ont beaucoup de charbon et qui ont
été pendant longtemps sous embargo la
communauté internationale donc sans
accès au pétrole et qui n'ont pas de
pétrole ont aussi utilisé ce procédé
pour faire avancer leur voiture et dur
est aujourd'hui le leader mondial
technique sur les questions de
liquéfaction du charbon c'est à dire de
conversion de charbon en hydrocarbures
liquides de synthèse
c'est une société sud-africaine qui
s'appelle sasol qui est l'un des leaders
mondial les mondiaux par don sinon le
leader mondial de ce genre de
technologie donc avec du charbon vous
fait avancer les voitures c'est juste
une question d'investissement alors
c'est pas juste une question
d'investissement parce qu'il a quand il
y avoir une question dans de grandes
heures dans tout ça mais c'est
techniquement possible
avec du gaz vous pouvez faire des
hydrocarbures liquides de synthèse avec
du charbon vous pouvez faire du gaz
le fameux gaz à l'eau qui a alimenté les
réverbères parisien était fait comme ça
vous savez on fait passer de l'eau sur
du charbon
qui est à haute température et vous
obtenez du gaz à l'eau c'est à dire un
mélange de monoxyde de carbone et
d'hydrogène dans ça fait boum donc vous
aviez vous avez la possibilité de passer
de l'un à l'autre
on peut faire de la chimie organique et
du charbon ça ne pose absolument aucun
problème
suffit de gazéifier pour commencer donc
vous avez la possibilité d'utiliser un
distinctement l'un de ces hydrocarbures
techniquement économiquement non plus
que les rendements sont pas les mêmes
partout etc
mais techniquement vous pouvez alors on
peut s'amuser à jouer à un petit jeu
auquel on va jouer plus tard qui et
j'imagine que je n'ai tout ça dans un
même gros paquet combien de temps est-ce
que je peux faire tenir le monde
combien de temps est-ce que je peux
avoir un approvisionnement croissant en
hydrocarbures en considérant que la
contrainte climatique n'est pas un sujet
c'est un petit calcul que je vous
proposerai après mais encore une fois si
vous reprenez les valeurs brutes
notez que si on fait une répartition de
l'inventaire fossiles mondiale on a un
peu de gaz un peu de pétrole et broutent
charmant après autre chose dont il faut
se souvenir et ça ça sera majeur je vous
repasserait quand on parlera des
renouvelables c'est qu'aujourd'hui
l'énergie fossile
globalement son extraction voir prix
ridicule et quand vous montez et il faut
augmenter pas beaucoup le prix de
l'énergie pour que à peu près tout ce
que je vous ai montré sur le graphique
précédent soit économiquement
intéressant encore à ça près ici vous
avez les coûts d'extraction du pétrole
stricto sensu décomposée en trois bars
c'est à dire ceux qui relèvent de
l'exploration dont je me balade avec mon
échographe là je fait boum un peu
partout et je regarde s'il ya et je fais
des trous surtout les troubles y coûte
cher ensuite ce qui a trait au
développement donc le développement
c'est j'ai trouvé du pétrole et je
demande à
coflexip technip bertin et autres de me
confère la plateforme de me construire
les tuyaux etc et enfin derrière j'ai
une partie production on va faut que je
paye les ouvriers il faut que je paye de
transport il faut que c'est alors vous
voyez que dans le désert saoudien
le bar in his or à moins de 5 dollars à
moins de 5 dollars et le prix moyen du
baril il se balade à moins de 10 dollars
à moins de 10 dollars le kilowattheure
vous 0 4 centime d'euro véhicules
ridicule vous signale pour comparaison
que le tarif garanti de rachat à
résidence et du kilowattheure finale
électrique de l'éolien c'est 8
en ce qui concerne le photovoltaïque
c'est quand donc pour des raisons
physiques pour des raisons physiques
l'énergie fossile ne vaut rien parce que
la nature a fait tout seul pour nous pas
voir qu'on existait pas une opération à
comme je voulais montrer tout à l'heure
10.7 de rendement kratos rien payer pour
un africain en en ridicule et qui a fait
pour nous quelque chose d'absolument
extraordinaire qui s'appelle le pétrole
et qui n'a pas d'équivalent dans les
énergies renouvelables pas d'équivalent
physique et donc comme on paye que le
travail humain dans le prix de l'énergie
c'est ce que je vous ai expliqué la
dernière fois le travail humain
nécessaire pour obtenir à kilowattheure
de pétrole il est extrêmement bas y'a
pas grand chose à investir ça renvoie la
question tout à l'heure il n'y a pas
grand-chose à investir pour avoir hâte
d'essence dans son réservoir à 80
dollars le baril on va dire la quasi
totalité des gisements fossiles sont
accessibles
là il s'agit simplement des gisements
d'hydrocarbures liquides ou quasi
liquide mais c'est pareil pour les
charbons le prix du baril de carburant
liquide ex charbon en sortie d' unité de
liquéfaction or contraint de co2 nous
coûte à peu près 50 dollars doc à 100
dollars le baril
vous êtes capable de crâne et la
totalité des réserves ultimes de
combustibles fossiles sur terre à 100
dollars le baril on est capable de le
faire alors je disais tout à l'heure où
est ce que nous emmène la croissance à
2% par an voilà un exercice que vous
savez faire comme moi je prends la
consommation d'énergie fossile de
l'humanité dans les années 2000 là
j'avais fait démarrer dessus sur un
exercice aujourd'hui l'argovien résultat
qui est d'un peu moins de 10 milliards
de tonnes équivalent pétrole en goguette
à 9 à peu près vous fait croître sa 2%
par an faire que vous prolonger la
tendance passée et vous regardez au bout
de combien de temps est-ce que le cumul
de ce que vous avez consommé vaut le
haut de la fourchette de l'évaluation
sur les réserves ultimes en ce qui
concerne l'agrégat charbon gaz et
pétrole donc en clair le traduit sans en
français combien de temps il faut pour
tout ramener à 2% de croissance de la
consommation d'énergie fossile par an et
la réponse est un siècle comme bien
évidemment avec ma fonction qui passe
par un maximum et qui tend vers zéro
je ne vais pas avoir le maximum leur la
seconde et le jour qui vont qui va
précéder le zéro ça c'est l'hypothèse
des théories d'un tout le monde et tué
instantanément
mais comme ces vraisemblement pas ça qui
va se passer ça veut dire que le maximum
de la consommation d'énergie fossile et
vraisemblablement pour le siècle qui
vient est en fait vous allez voir tout à
fait à la fin que on serait relativement
bien inspirés de le provoquer
délibérément pour des raisons
climatiques et de ne pas attendre qui se
passe tout seul
j'ai par exemple des collègues
si l'on peut dire à electricité de
france qui ont fait cette petite
simulation dans lequel ils ont pris un
inventaire mondial des réserves ultimes
en pétrole qui donne un pic en 2020 que
vous avez
et puis ils ont pris pour les autres
ressources fossiles
c'est pareil des inventaires mondiaux en
ce qui concerne le gaz
ils ont considéré que pour le charbon on
avait cette fois les réserves ultimes
accessible en pétrole donc ils ont
repris plus tôt le haut de la fourchette
en ce qui concerne le charbon il n'y a
pas loupé spécialiste du charbon en
france n'en fallait quelques-uns avec
l'idée discutée considèrent qu'ils ont
été plutôt dans le haut de la fourchette
que dans le bas de la fourchette et ils
se sont amusés à regarder à quelle
échéance
est ce que on aurait le pic mondial de
production d'énergie pas seulement de
pétrole de production d'énergie tout
confondu en tirant tant qu'on peut sur
les sources
actuellement disponibles alors ces
sources actuellement disponibles quelles
sont elles vous avez ici le pétrole
conventionnel vous avez ici le non
conventionnel dont vous voyez tout est
une question d'ordre de grandeur et je
vous rappelle encore une fois que la
longueur du reportage à la télévision
n'est pas proportionnelle à l'enjeu pour
l'humanité ça n'a rien à voir c'est pas
comme ça que les journalistes fonctionne
de même que c'est pas la compétence
technique des intervenants qui fait leur
sélection sur un plateau de télévision
c'est pas ça c'est pas ça ça n'est pas
ça ce soir je suis invité à une émission
de télévision
personne ne m'a demandé ce que j'avais
publié comme papier personne ne m'a fait
passer le moindre examen avant d'inviter
personnes et si je me retrouve ce soir
en face de gens qui disent que du
pétrole y en a encore pour deux siècles
on ne leur a en aura pas plus vérifier
la qualité technique de leurs travaux
pas plus
si monsieur allègre est invitée partout
c'est pas parce que les journalistes ont
vérifié qui racontait quelque chose de
crédible c'est parce qu'il commet il est
mondial et il ya que ça qui les
intéressent le reste il s'en fiche c'est
pas ça qui fait de l'audience qui fait
de l'audience c'est d'abord une grande
gueule donc il faut bien voir que le
système médiatique qui a ses propres
contraintes
ce sont des ce sont des entreprises
économiques pour besoin d'avoir des
auditeurs qui ont besoin d'avoir des
lecteurs faut pas leur jeter la pierre
je fais exactement les choses à leur
place ils ont des contraintes leurs
recettes publicitaires dépendent de leur
audience et pour avoir beaucoup de gens
qui regardent où beaucoup de gens qui
lisent où beaucoup de gens qui écoutent
il est préférable de dire des choses pas
trop compliqué et si possible que les
gens se tapent dessus est du reste je
rappelle que quand j'étais gamin
j'adorais les émissions genre taper
dessus
quand on invitait marché à une émission
politique jeu tout de suite j'ai allumé
la télévision
je me rappelle absolument pas qu'ils y
restent ce qui était juste rigolo
c'était de voir sombrer avec les autres
donc il faut bien voir que le cahier des
charges
le cahier des charges d'une émission
grand public sauf dans quelques cas très
particulier n'est pas avant tout de dire
des choses vraies c'est avant tout de
dire des choses distrayante avant tout
de dire des choses il faut le savoir
surtout une fois vous le savez il ya pas
de malentendu il faut juste savoir donc
j'en reviens à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure
ne pensez pas une seconde je voulais
déjà dit la dernière fois sur les
renouvelables que l'importance de la
pagination d'un sujet dans le journal
est représentative de son importance
dans la vie réelle ça n'est pas comme ça
que fonctionne la presse même quand elle
est de bonne volonté même quand elle est
de bonne volonté
si ça vous intéresse on pourra faire un
demi heure d'explications texte sur la
manière dont ça fonctionne ce truc là
donc ici je vous dis il ya le pic de
production du pétrole en 2020 le pétrole
non conventionnel qui adoucit la pente
derrière on va dire dans ce scénario là
le gaz continue sa croissance et passe
son pic à peu près une dizaine d'années
derrière le pétrole à peu près une
dizaine d'années derrière le pétrole
ici vous êtes dans un scénario dans
lequel on considère que le nucléaire
croit suffisamment pour que areva et du
mal à produire avec un carnet de
commandes bien rempli vous avez une
croissance plus modérée en termes
relatifs des deux renouvelables qui
compte aujourd'hui que son
l'hydroélectricité et la biomasse la
biomasse parce que vous avez une
limitation sur les surfaces de forêt
accessible et d'hydroélectricité parce
que vous avez une opposition sociale à
la construction de nouveaux barrages qui
en général est assez forte ou avait qu'à
voir ce qui s'est passé aux trois gorges
les trois gorges s'est parfaitement
renouvelables je vous rappelle mais il
ya un certain nombre de gens qui ont
considéré que c'est gbagbo est
renouvelable n'était pas propre
et encore une fois je vous rappelle ce
que je vous ai dit la dernière fois il
n'y a pas d'énergie propre il n'y a pas
d'énergie sales c'est la dose qui fait
le poison donc un certain nombre de gens
qui considèrent que passé un certain
seuil ça cesse dépend donc toujours est
il que biomasse et l'hydroélectricité
c'est la voici
les nouvelles renouvelables qui sont
faites très anciennes comme je voulais
dit la dernière fois et il faut attendre
allez il faut attendre que vous soyez à
la retraite avant que ça sorte de
l'épaisseur du trait même avec des taux
de croissance qui sont extrêmement
élevés parce que sa part d' extrêmement
bas voilà encore une fois je reviens à
ce que je vous dis je t'ai de préciser
un tout petit peu le journal parle de
l'éolien à chaque fois qu'il reçoit un
communiqué de presse de quelqu'un qui a
installé une éolienne
une éolienne s'est considérablement
moins qu'un barrage sauf que en ce
moment en france personnes installent
des barrages la france fait plus
d'électricité d'origine renouvelable
danemark 14% en france 12 % au danemark
sauf que comme en france on est à plus
de barrages on parle pas d'hydraulique à
chaque fois qu'on installe une éolienne
on vous parle de l'éolien est la
personne qui ne fait que lire le journal
je dis donc ça doit être très important
donc c'est pas comme ça que ça marche
encore une fois le journal réagi à une
information qu'il vient de l'extérieur
en l'occurrence un communiqué de presse
alors j'en reviens à ce que je à ce que
je disais et ici vous avez un appel au
charbon qui va aussi vite que possible
et aussi loin que possible avec des
ressources en charbon qui sont
considérées être cette fois supérieure
aux ressources en préservant charbon qui
sont cette fois supérieur au real en
pétrole une partie de ce charbon donne
déjà lieu à de la conversion en
hydrocarbures liquides
c'est ce que vous avez ici et l'
enveloppe que vous avez là c'est la
prolongation tendancielle de la
consommation d'énergie c'est donc le 2 %
pas de croissance par an du pouvoir
d'achat et de la consommation d'énergie
qui va avec
eh bien vous voyez que dans ce genre de
scénario dès 2025 2030
vous avez une tension sur les
hydrocarbures liquides je parle bien des
hydrocarbures liquides et dès 2040 2050
vous avez une tension sur la production
énergétique globale ce que je suis en
train de vous dire c'est que même en
incluant le gaz et le charbon
la question de la contrainte sur
l'approvisionnement énergétique globale
est un truc qui vous concernera de votre
vivant même en accueillant de charbon
les arbres ne montent pas jusqu'au ciel
vous en était peut-être déjà persuadé
mais je vous le rappelle donc un jour ça
s'arrête et en fait vous allez voir un
peu après que il sera même souhaitable
de ne pas attendre 2050 pour que la
consommation mondiale d'énergie diminue
parce que le fait de passer de la la
j'ai un transparent dans de slide dont
je vous en dis pas plus rajoutera une
addition climatique dont déjà vous
verriez la trace et dont vos enfants
pour laquelle allez on va dire si je
suis un tout petit peu provocant que vos
enfants vous diront avant même de buter
sur les limites géologique
parce que c'est bien ça dont il s'agit
bien avant même de buter sur les limites
géologique
je vais rappeler une autre limite qui
est la limite que je pourrais qualifier
de géopolitique
je vous ai montré tout à l'heure et je
vais peut-être y revenir très rapidement
où était situé l'essentiel des réserves
d'hydrocarbures
alors cette fois je vais prendre juste
alors quelles sont les réserves
d'hydrocarbures
josé perdu
mais voilà
regardez où sont situés les réserves
majeures de gaz et de pétrole
je vous rappelle que le pétrole c'est 35
% de l'approvisionnement énergétique
mondial de gaz 20 donc gaz et pétrole
c'est plus de la moitié de
l'approvisionnement énergétique mondial
alors regardez où sont situées les
grandes réserves de gaz et de pétrole en
russie en iran en arabie saoudite au
qatar dans un certain nombre de pays du
golfe au venezuela au koweït et c
c'est-à-dire pour l'essentiel devant des
pays qui le consomme qu'une petite
partie de ce qu'ils produisent le
consomme qu'une petite partie de ce
qu'il produit
ça veut donc dire que pour la plus de la
moitié de l'approvisionnement
énergétique mondial
les réserves ne sont pas situés là où a
lieu la production donc en gros tout le
monde veut un gâteau qui n'est situé
chez aucun des grands pays consommateurs
tout le monde veut un gâteau qui n'est
situé chez aucun des grands pays
consommateurs
alors je vous pose la question commence
à se dessiner une tension sur
l'approvisionnement énergétique mondial
qu'est-ce qui se passe pardon
probablement probablement il faut quand
même savoir que quand on regarde les
guerres qui ont eu lieu au 20e et au 19e
siècle il y en a énormément pour
lesquels on peut se demander si les
questions énergétiques n'était pas
présente peu ou prou dans l'ariège dans
l'abandon dans la partie arrière la de
la boîte crânienne des gens qui les ont
déclenché les guerres par exemple entre
la france et l'allemagne ont concerné un
territoire deux territoires l'alsace et
la lorraine qui avaient des ressources
important qu'en minerai de fer et en
charbon
ça n'a probablement pas été complètement
neutre dans les conflits qui ont occupé
cette cette zone
et puis si vous regardez ça d'une
manière un peu plus large
vous vous rendez compte qu'en fait
l'accès aux ressources a été de tout
temps un motif de conflit
absolument majeur donc le pétrole
restant là je vais parler juste des
réserves prouvées ils se situent aux
deux tiers avec l'incertitude que je
vous ai évoqué tout à l'heure sur la
véracité des chiffres qui sont publiés
par les compagnies nationale 2
les états au moyen-orient c'est à dire
dans une zone qui est assez peu
consommatrices d'hydrocarbures cela
étant dans un contexte dans lequel le
prix de marché monde tout seul ces gens
là vont s'enrichir
donc ils vont consommer plus d'énergie
ce qui veut dire que la fraction
disponible pour l'exportation devraient
si c'est la hausse du prix de marché qui
nous ramène à la raison
baisser plus vite que la production tout
court la part que ces gens là se
réserveront pour eux mêmes en
s'enrichissant augmentera au détriment
nécessairement de ski et réservées à
l'exportation
donc ce qui va partir à l'exportation a
toutes les chances dans un tel contexte
spontanément en tant qu a pas d'autres
régulation et de gens qui s'en va et
c'est là pas réservées à l'exportation
devrait baisser plus vite que la
production stricto sensu donc deux tiers
du pétrole sont au moyen-orient et en
europe où sauf erreur de ma part nous
vivons il reste 1 25 % des réserves de
pétrole mondiale pour le pétrole il est
partout sauf chez nous en ce qui
concerne le gaz même motif même punition
je dit tout à l'heure que la russie
avait les premières réserves de gaz au
monde
effectivement monsieur poutine est assis
sur à peu près 30% d'un poutine qu'il
est plus que premier ministre comme
chacun sait est assis sur 30% des
réserves gazières mondiales
donc c'est important de bien s'entendre
avec monsieur poutine sachant que quand
les chinois vont commencer à vouloir du
gaz pour des tas de raisons parfaitement
légitime ou en tout cas au chili et king
cole et au genou que la russie et entre
la chine et nous listons qu'une bonne
partie des gisements gaziers ils sont
plutôt vers l'est de la chine de la
russie pardon voit la question qui va
gagner 6 et nos amis de l'est lointain
qui gagne il est évident que le prix
pour d'eau
il sera un peu plus élevé voire beaucoup
plus élevé donc tous les électriciens
français qui en ce moment sont en train
de se lancer dans la construction de
turbines à gaz qui vont durer vingt
trente quarante cinquante ans reste à
voir s'ils sont en train de se rendre un
très bon service et a lui aussi en
europe 3 % du gaz restaurant voilà en
europe occidentale
je vous disais tout à l'heure et ça
c'est valable pour la production aussi
en france on importe 99 % du pétrole
qu'on consomme et 97
en tout cas ce qu'on consomme nous
sommes donc totalement vulnérables à la
volatilité des prix sur les marchés
internationaux dans le contexte qui
s'annonce totalement vulnérable et enfin
le charbon alors là je vous ai mis juste
les réserves prouvées et vient le
charbon je vous ai montré tout à l'heure
quelques grands pays charbonnier je vais
les reprendre certes il a l'air mieux
répartie par continent certes il possède
une caractéristique absolument majeur
c'est que les réserves sont beaucoup
plus situés dans les zones de
consommation
il n'empêche que le charbon plus de 85%
du char ou à peu près 85 % du charbon
mondial est détenu par six pays
seulement qui sont dans l'ordre les
états unis la russie l'inde la chine
l'australie et l'afrique du sud
une fois vous avez fait le tour de ces
six pays vous avez inventorié 85% du
charbon mondiale alors je vous pose une
question vous allez commencer à avoir
des tensions sur le pétrole et sur le
gaz parce que mon pronostic c'est que
les tensions sur l'approvisionnement
pétrolier se manifesteront probablement
avant la saine gestion appliquée aux
émissions de gaz à effet de serre pour
limiter le changement climatique plus
tard je pense que les échéances tant qu
elles font que avant que les gens
commencent à décider de baisser de 4%
par an et pour de vrai leurs émissions
de gaz à effet de serre le pic pétrolier
arrivera et la récession se chargera de
faire la même chose les pays charbonnier
qui ont la possibilité de convertir leur
charbon en hydrocarbures liquides de
synthèse au prix d'investissements
extrêmement coûteux mener pour partie en
période de récession
ils ont le choix entre trois
éventualités et là on commence à rentrer
dans le jeu intéressant des paris la
première éventualité et de dire je veux
être sérieux avec le climat je ne touche
pas à mon charbon ça c'est la première
éventualité
donc il faut que la russie accepte cette
idée que les états unis acceptent cette
idée d'état d'états souverains qui font
ce qu'ils veulent chez eux et à mon avis
il est assez peu question d envahir donc
la russie doit faire ça
les etats unis doivent faire ça l'inde
et la chine
ça je pense que c'est aussi assez peu
question d envahir pourra éventuellement
vers l'afrique du sud peut être et
encore mais voilà mais les autres
n'auraient pas la peine d'y penser
donc ces pays là il faut qu'il faut
arriver à les convaincre à les
convaincre
alors les convaincre en économie ça
porte un nom très simple c'est à dire
les pays ça veut dire que nous pays
occidentaux aux consommateurs en pleine
période de récession
on devra convaincre les électeurs qu'il
faut qu'il paye encore plus d'impôts
pour payer les américains les chinois et
russes pour pas qu'ils utilisent leur
charbon fréquemment ça que ça va vous le
redire deuxième option
ces gens là disent je vais produire des
hydrocarbures liquides de synthèse mais
comme ça coûte très cher j'en fais pour
moi et les autres tant pas à ce moment
en europe occidentale on se retrouve
dans un contexte dans lequel on se prend
un la récession parce qu'il n'ya plus
assez d'hydrocarbures liquides et que ça
fait exploser les prix et deux les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
croissante de la part des pays
charbonnier donc là on a tout gagné
ça veut dire que l'on se prend à la fois
la récession tout de suite à cause des
problèmes énergétiques et la récession
plus tard à cause du changement
climatique parce que c'est aussi comme
ça que cette histoire est terminée mais
ça je vous en parlerai la prochaine fois
et la troisième éventualité c'est que
ces pays là à fond d investissement
tellement massif qui sont capables de se
substituer à l'arabie saoudite
d'aujourd'hui pour produire des
hydrocarbures liquides à vitesse
accélérée et alors ça c'est mon scénario
charbon aux que vous avez ici et ce
scénario charbon aux que vous avez ici
m'amène à ce petit tableau qui va faire
la transition avec le cours de la
prochaine fois qui vous dit les choses
suivantes ce petit tableau dans la
première colonne vous avez la
concentration atmosphérique de co2 à
laquelle on imagine que le système
climatique se stabilise
on dit voilà les émissions nous
conduisent à stabiliser la concentration
à ce niveau là dans la oublier en
parlera prochaine fois ici vous avez la
correspondance avec le moment où le pic
des émissions de co2 est passé en gros
ça vous dit que si le pic des émissions
de co2 est passé dans les années 2000
eh bien ça veut dire qu'il faut pas
aller plus haut que ça veut dire qu'on
n'ira pas plus haut que 350 à 450 ppm
co2 dans l'atmosphère parties par
million et inversement si on veut pas
monter au dessus de 400 ou 450
il faut que le pic des émissions de co2
et lieu aux alentours de 2010 donc en
gros la semaine prochaine et ici vous
avez la correspondance avec
l'augmentation de température à terme
que l'on aura pour le système climatique
donc en gros le fait de taper de viser
le scénario charbon aux pour nous
libérer de la contrainte de ressources
sur l'approvisionnement pétrolier et
pouvoir continuer à faire croître le
pouvoir d'achat dont on peut largement
discuté le fait que ce soit une
augmentation de notre richesse puisque
ça s'accompagne d'une dette
sauf qu'il faudra la payer plus tard et
bien si vous augmentez donc la
contribution du charbon et du gaz
histoire de lever la contrainte sur le
pétrole
ça revient à dire que vous faites passer
le pic des émissions de co2 de 2010 à
et ça ça veut dire que vous achetez une
addition climatique qui au lieu d'être
plus 2 devient plus sage et ça on verra
aux deux prochains course que ça ce que
ça signifie de passer de +2 à +5
mais pour vous donner déjà une
conclusion provisoire
ça veut dire que on passe d'un bazar qui
va être très significatif et peut-être
encore gérable à quelque chose qui a
toutes les chances de terminer en vingt
ans donc il faut bien voir que
l'essentiel après que sérieux très
sérieux
l'essentiel
l'essentiel de 2 pardon
on est à 380 on est à 380 plus ou moins
quelque chose parce que ça change tous
les ans comme disait l'autre
l'a380 il ya mais ça je vous en parlerai
aux deux prochains cours il ya des gens
qui pensent qu'aujourd'hui avec ce qu'on
a déjà vu dans l'atmosphère on n'a pas
seulement acheté + 1 de manière
absolument certaine mais plutôt +3 déjà
pardon aux échelles aux échelles de
temps plus longue en gros ce qui va se
passer à partir de maintenant va avoir
une influence absolument fondamental
mais ce qu'il va se passer à l'échelle
d'une génération vous moi pour ce qui
reste à vivre
un papa à des horizons de temps
immémoriaux ce qui va se passer dans les
quelques décennies qui viennent va
fondamentalement je dis bien
fondamentalement régir les conditions de
vie à la surface de la planète pour des
temps qui eux vont être extrêmement long
et ça va commencer dans pas très
longtemps cette affaire-là
alors je sais pas si c'est une chance ou
une malchance vous arrivé à un tournant
l'histoire des hommes
je vous l'avais déjà dit la dernière
fois vous arrivez à un tournant
démographique
on a connu une explosion sans précédent
vous arrivez à tournan de consommation
énergétique
là vous allez arriver à un tournant en
ce qui concerne l'évolution de la courbe
de production qui n'a jamais décru
depuis qu'on a commencé à utiliser
d'énergie et la prochaine fois je ferai
la première des deux parties où je vous
expliquerai qu'on est aussi en train
d'arriver à un tournant climatique
donc il y aura un premier volet sur le
changement climatique et lundi prochain
ça sera sur les conséquences vous
exactement sur ce qu'on est capable de
dire sur les conséquences du changement
climatique et vous verrez qu'on est
capable de dire juste une petite partie
de celui là pour le remplacer
voilà et je vous remercie